dans ce territoire de moyenne montagne
vivent un peu plus de 78 mille habitants
cette circonscription est la moins
peuplée du jura l'actualité de saint
claude la plus grande ville est marquée
par le projet de réorganisation de
l'hôpital
les élus craignent la fermeture de
l'établissement après cinq ans dans
l'opposition
la députée sortante des républicains
marie christine dalloz espère faire
partie de la majorité parlementaire pour
pouvoir agir
le projet que nous portons c'est un euro
investi en ville doit avoir l'équivalent
en euros investis en dans la ruralité
c'est comme ça qu'on aidera la ruralité
un vrai plan marshall un moratoire sur
la fermeture des services publics
je pense bien sûr à l'hôpital aux
hôpitaux de proximité l'hôpital de
saint-claude mais aussi celui de mort et
champagnole le maire de saint claude
s'est déclaré candidat au dernier moment
sa principale motivation défendre
l'hôpital rencontrer les décideurs au
plus haut niveau en direct et les
convaincre il faut qu'il vienne à 5o qui
viennent dans le jura pour se rendre
compte de ce que c'est notre spécificité
géographique et topographiques sens la
vue depuis paris dans un bureau surtout
une carte à plat sur une table je dire
qu'il est impossible de se rendre compte
l'hôpital de saint-claude est aussi un
des premiers thèmes de campagne de la
candidate en marche
anne prose grosjean elle compte se
servir de son réseau au gouvernement
pour sauver ce service public et elle
défend le projet d' emmanuel macron en
matière de santé dans le projet emmanuel
macron il y a
une lutte contre la désertification des
campagnes et il a proposé un doublement
des maisons de santé
mais je pense que ne s'arrêtera pas là
qui sera très sensible au fait qu'on ne
peut pas laisser un territoire isolé
sans hôpital et sans soins médicaux
nathalie desseigne la candidate du fn
veut appliquer une proposition de marine
le pen supprimer l'aide médicale d'état
aux étrangers en situation irrégulière
pour que la sécurité sociale réalise des
économies
le problème c'est que la sécurité
sociale et un déficit donc ne veut pas
des idées les hôpitaux
et puis deuxièmement les hôpitaux comme
ils tous les services publics ne sont
pas là pour être rentable donc c'est
normal qu'un hôpital soit déficitaire
puisque la santé n'a pas de prix
la france en soumises a lancé partout en
france des ateliers citoyens notamment
autour de la santé qui a une
problématique la candidate julie lens on
veut s'appuyer sur ses propositions pour
maintenir les services hospitaliers
concrètement on défend d'un point de vue
national une défense du service de santé
du service public en général avec une
restructuration n'est contre les ars
donc automatiquement on ira sur cette
politique les écologistes le ps et le pc
qui présentent une candidature commune
dès fin de compte elle une autre
distribution des fonds pour financer les
hôpitaux les candidats sont unanimes ils
veulent agir pour l'hôpital les
électeurs de la deuxième circonscription
du jura doivent faire leur choix entre
des projets qui s'opposent
[Musique]